from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills it's
election day and record-breaking numbers
of people are casting their ballots
this is particularly noticeable in texas
where voters have already surpassed the
number of ballots cast
in the entirety of the 2016 election
before the polls even opened today
joining us to discuss how voting is
working in houston and across the state
of texas
is mayor turner mr mayor thank you so
much for joining us today
thanks for having me so i want to just
jump right in here
how is voting going across the state of
texas and
particularly in your district have there
been any issues in
in polling stations that have come up
for you today
you know on balance madison things have
gone well
uh people are proceeding to vote uh
there's been
minimal intimidation factors we've we've
had some people
uh i guess they call themselves the
election protectors people with the uh
with the uh the trump campaign uh
dressed in dark
clothing uh that have gone to a number
of polling places and
sat down kind of like in front of the
polling
uh places uh far enough away you know
within legal
the legal geographical limits kind of
serving as uh
and like an intimidation factor but
people have simply ignored them
and have pushed right through uh they
are determined to vote so
uh but there hasn't been any what i call
any direct confrontation which is good
so by and large things have gone quite
well it's a beautiful day in the city of
houston
uh 70 degrees sunshiny weather and
and people are people are exercising
their fundamental rights
and moving ahead from tonight do you
anticipate any violence or
unrest if either candidate wins i've
heard from several voters across the
state of texas today who
are a bit concerned about vigilante
activity
if biden takes this election for example
you know i'm hoping that things will
remain uh very peaceful
that people will celebrate the rights of
people to participate in the election
process
now we of course we prepared for the
worst hoping for the very very best and
so we are hoping that everyone
regardless of who they vote for
regardless of
what the outcome of the elections will
be tonight or tomorrow or two or three
days from now
that people will continue to be very
respectful
of the process regardless of whether or
not your person
uh prevails or not so uh we haven't
heard a lot of chatter
you know there's been some but by and
large
uh uh it has things have gone well
uh i've not gotten any re reports from
from the law enforcement agencies in the
city uh
that they are con overly concerned about
anything
uh but we have we look we partnered up
with uh
county law enforcement agencies as well
as others so we've got people positioned
you know all all over the city again
we're we're hopeful
that things will will be fine and we are
asking people to
simply exercise their right to vote and
then respect the process
whatever the outcomes may be
and millions of people have been
recognizing their right to vote across
the state of texas
uh why do you think voters are so
energized to vote in this election
season
in particular well people are engaged
madison
in this for this election is personal
when you think for example of 230
000 americans who have lost their lives
to the coronavirus
um well over what eight million people
who have come down with the virus
many of them for example are senior
citizens
uh people of color um i mean people are
engaged
um this is a a time in which the country
appears to be more divided than
ever which is not good people are
exhausted
of things that have taken place in this
in this country for example over the
last four years
um so people i think are tired of the
division
people are tired of one group being pit
against
another we are proud americans and we
recognize
that where we are at this moment in time
we're not operating at our very best
and so um so for many for many people
when like they've either lost their jobs
or been furloughed because of
the continuation this the way this virus
has been handled
um this is a very personal election
for so many families so so many uh
individuals young people this younger
generation they're concerned about
their future we have had more younger
people
vote in this election uh more than
doubled than what took place in 2016.
give me an example in the state of texas
over 800
000 of the people who have voted are
people under the age of 30 and below
66 of that number
of students and young younger
individuals
who did not vote at all in 2016.
so they they're taking they have a
personal stake and they're concerned
about their future
and they're voting not for yesterday
they are voting for tomorrow
and the days and weeks and years to come
mr mayor you mentioned the
record-breaking number of
young people who are voting in this
election uh and it seems that there's
certainly a lot of energy around this
election throughout the state of texas
i'm wondering how you'll plan to handle
just the number
of incoming ballots uh what's the plan
for
counting these ballots out and what will
you do if perhaps the results in texas
are contested by one of the candidates
well i will tell you that chris hollins
who is a
is a a young person um
the county clerk of harris county the
harris county clerk chris holland has
done a
masterful job of making voting
accessible
to people throughout harris county he's
been innovative he's put together
an outstanding team and they've just
done a marvelous marvelous job
and as a result more people voted early
this year then all more so than all the
people who voted in 2016
for the entire election cycle in 2016.
so that speaks volumes
uh i usually for example the mayor's
college challenge
challenging the students at texas
southern university
university of houston and rice to
compete amongst themselves their
campuses as who could come up
with the most votes on their respective
campuses since we had voting at those
particular locations
and today for example along with chris
highlands average county clerk
we gave that award out to rice
university those three college campuses
alone
had more than 21 000 persons who voted
on their respective campuses
so the students like my daughter uh
engaged in the process
they've been participating in the
process and rice university that polling
place was manned
by nothing but students themselves
so um now we're expecting a lot of
numbers to come in
uh a little after seven o'clock central
time for example
that 1.4 million people who cast their
vote during the early voting process
those results will be announced uh in
harris county
so it's not going to in in harris county
in texas this is not going to be a
situation
where people are going to have to wait
you know two or three days i think we're
going to have
some results um um maybe late into the
night but certainly i think in the next
24 hours we'll know what the results
will be in in the state of texas
and specifically uh how people vote in
harris county
that's i'm sure very exciting for a lot
of people listening to this who are
really hoping
to get a result tonight but i am curious
moving ahead
from the results let's say we do get a
result from texas within the next 24
hours
what if one of the candidates contests
the results how do you
and other lawmakers throughout texas
plan to respond to that
well you know we still you know i still
believe in the in the legal process
uh this is a great this is a great
country i think we all take uh
an oath to the constitution uh that we
will protect the rights as defined in
the constitution itself
um and you know people have the right to
contest that is their that is their
right
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
they will prevail on the marriage
and so i think when all is said and done
i think
the funding there's a fundamental
principle that when people
cast their vote when they get registered
and when they vote in a in a process
that's been duly sanctioned for example
by the county by the secretary of state
by the state of texas for example
or any other jurisdiction that their
votes should be
valid their votes should count to the
extent
uh a person believes that
they have been wronged and they want to
contest that within the judicial process
that is their right it's my hope though
that the judicial system
will look at it will judge those claims
based on the merits
and if those claims are not meritorious
then they will be rejected
if their claims are meritorious then we
will deal with them accordingly
but i am one uh i'm the mayor of this
city i've been in the legislature in the
legislature for 27 years
i've been a lawyer for 40 years i've
been an american
for as long as i have lived i believe
in this country that the the principles
for which
many people have fought and died that
those principles are still very much
alive today
and they will be on it in this
democratic process that we call
voting i can't help but be reminded with
some of the language you're using about
some of the speeches i was lucky to hear
you give
uh on the campaign trail i'm curious uh
what has the experience
of this election cycle been like for you
on the local level
uh it feels like this has gone on for
years so what what has that been like
for you
just experiencing this campaign as a
local official
let me tell you this has been a needle
this has been an election season like
none other uh not only has this been a
very
uh painstaking year 2020 but with the
corona virus
and everything that people have suffered
uh but this election
season seemed like it has gone on for
for quite for quite some time
it's been not only competitive but it's
been highly divisive
the rhetoric the language um the
allegations
the things that have been said um i've
made it a very difficult year for so far
for so many it's my hope that
that as we move forward that this
country will will find this way
one of the things that i've said many
many times on the campaign trail and
things that i've posted
is that there comes a point in time when
you have to hit the reset button
okay when you have to recognize that
when you're going off
of course and you have to set a new
chart a new course that you have to re
set hit the reset button
this is one of those times and i'm
hoping uh when this uh when all the
votes have been cast
when the votes have been cast that the
american people will have hit the reset
button
and this country will again uh recognize
that we are the united states of america
that it doesn't matter who the mayor may
be
it doesn't matter what party that may or
may be
with or whether uh whether you're a
democratic mayor republican mayor
democratic governor republican governor
it does not matter that we all are
americans
and that well whoever wins you represent
not only those
who voted for you but you also represent
those who voted against you in fact
once the once that votes have been
counted
and a winner has been proclaimed then
you forget
about whether or not it was 51
49 or 55 45 percent
you represent 100 of the people
in your city or in your state or
in your country and i'm hoping that we
will
uh whoever is chosen will recognize that
and will serve in the in the best
interest of the united states
of america and the only question that
one should ask is what's in the best
centers of our country
or our state or our county or our city
that's that's my that's my hope and i i
just believe
that that will take place madison and so
i'm i'm still
very much excited you know i uh i did
with my mom and dad
neither one of them graduated from high
school but for them
voting was a must okay
voting was a must and then they're not
here today
so but when i cast my vote i cast my
vote with them in mind
because uh it meant a great deal to them
and it means a great deal to me
and uh it means a great deal to my
daughter and for
for so many others that live within our
great country
thank you for sharing that mayor turner
is your daughter a first first-time
voter
no she uh my daughter voted for me when
i ran for mayor five years ago
and uh and but uh this was her first
time uh no this was not her first time
she voted
in 20 she voted in 2016. so this was her
second time voting in a presidential
in a presidential election i'm sure she
was very proud to be able to vote for
you
uh while we still have you we have a
couple minutes left i do want to ask you
about what you think about this
record-breaking turnout in texas
typically record-breaking turnout is
better for democrats but we're also
seeing that a lot of people are voting
in these more rural areas throughout
your state
which could lead to higher levels of
voters for trump
where do you predict this is gonna come
out i know that's a heavy-handed
question but where do you think
we're gonna see this result tomorrow
well number one let me just say this i'm
excited for for people to vote
regardless whether they're voting in
rural america whether they're voting in
suburban or in urban america
the very fact that people are exercising
the right to vote
is good in a democratic system and your
vote is your voice so that's
i have no problem with that at all um
and and i would encourage people to vote
regardless of where they live
geographically what their social
economic background may be
um that's i think that is good that is
good for
for for our democracy so that's number
one number two
uh and historically texas has been a low
voting state
uh this time around texas has reversed
that
we have come from being a low voting
state to be one of the best voting
states
uh so that tells you just how
consequential
and how important this election is and
so a lot of people have been voting
in 2016 8.7 8.9
million people voted in the state of
texas uh at the end of the early voting
process
last friday that number was 9.7 million
before anybody even started voting on
november 3rd
today tuesday so that number will be
much much higher
uh and for and for the first time in a
long time
texas is a competitive state very
competitive
i am hoping with all is said and done uh
that when people look at texas that they
will see that people in texas voted for
transformation
that we voted to sit hit the reset
button
and i think that's a good opportunity
for this texas to go from being
a low voting state to a high voting
state and a state that goes from being
red to being blue
if nothing else being very very much
purple and i think that's good for
everybody
in in our state and beyond and i will
tell you
to the extent for example if texas goes
from being
red to purple to blue it will transform
the political discourse
not only in the state of texas but in
this country as a whole
that's an interesting point do you think
that if texas goes blue
it will change the way the gop kind of
strategizes moving forward no not only
will it change the way the gop
strategizes
it will change the way the democratic
party strategizes
because uh texas will change the whole
equation
um what's on the line in in in today's
election for example is not just who
will be president of the united states
but the makeup of the texas house of
representatives since 2003 when i was in
the legislature
the texas house and the texas senate and
almost every statewide position
have been held by republicans today
in texas it is questionable whether or
not the texas house
will remain for example in republican
control of whether or not
it will flip if it flips that will be
monumental
because it will have been a long time
since that has taken place
and that will change the politics and
then bear in mind not only in the state
of texas but in other states across the
country
2021 will be a redistricting year
we'll start redrawing the lines and
legislatures
all across america and so the elections
that are taking place
today that will culminate today let me
put it that way
will not only impact the state in which
the presidential race
but it will impact congressional
districts
those lines uh state senatorial
districts
uh state legislative districts school
board districts
for the next 10 years so today
across the country in every state
it's not just about who will be the
president and the vice president of the
united states
but it will determine in large part how
the lines congressional lines and
legislative lines will be drawn that
will remain in place over the next
decade that's just how consequential uh
this election is
that's taking place that's culminating
today
and final question for you on those
consequences you mentioned some of these
down the ballot candidates are there any
folks in particular you're really
excited about
uh who are running for senate um or any
other down the ballot races that you're
looking into
you know we've got some outstanding
people who
are running for congressional seats um
so i'm looking at
i'm looking at several of those i'm
really paying a
very close attention to our texas
house you know texas the texas
legislature who will be serving
in the texas house of representatives
who will be serving in the texas senate
um look i've i spent 27 years in the
legislature
i know how important it is when it comes
to redrawing the lines
for congressional districts texas
legislative districts
uh senate districts and so uh
that's one of the reasons why this
election is just so consequential
so i'm really following uh very closely
who's going to prevail in those in those
texas house and senate seats
and then who's going to make up the uh
the texas congressional delegation
and then we've got some we've got a very
competitive uh united states senate race
in the texas in texas as well so uh i
tell people all the time
you know who's who's the elected
president of course
is very very important no question about
that
but many of the races that are down
below can be
have a greater impact in so many ways
on your day-to-day living on your
business
on um the criminal justice system your
healthcare system educational system
and so i tell people all the time don't
just go in and vote for the president
and then walk out away from the booth go
all the way down the ballot and make
sure that you are selecting
good people who will be representing you
at every level of government because
it's not one person not even the
president
that will impact your destiny but it's
the conglomerate
all of them put together that will have
a
an impact on your day-to-day living
as mayor of the city of houston i impact
for example
the pothole on your street the weeds in
your neighborhood
how your community is revitalized or
redeveloped
your police force your fire force your
municipal workers
on a daily basis so it's not just the
president
though that is a highly important
position but it's also
everyone that's serving below the
president so make sure that you go
all the way down the ballot and don't
shortchange yourself
mayor turner i could ask you questions
all night but i know you have a lot of
election watching to do yourself so we
are going to let you go but i can't
thank you enough for making time for us
and for those of you watching we're
going to be live at the top of every
hour tonight giving you the latest
election coverage that you need so stick
with us here at quick take for more
and have a great election night thanks
so much
thank you thanks for having me